Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 17th, 2012. Um,
I am emotionally exhausted from watching
that Patriots San Francisco game,
uh, last night. How insane
was that game? Unbelievable.
Um, unfortunately it was exactly what
I thought. Although the comeback,
I was amazed by that, but I, I've, I've,
I've gotten so much shit from a couple
of friends of mine who are patriots fans
because they feel like I'm not a patriots
fan anymore because I keep talking
about how bad our defenses and they
are one of those people who like,
you know, they like dress
like drew Bledsoe when they
watched the game. You know,
those people with it, this such fucking
fans, the no matter what's going on you,
you can never say anything what they
deem is like negative rather than
constructive criticism. But
you know, I feel vindicated
because last week when we beat the text
and say was sitting there going, yes,
what are you going to say now you're
ready. Yeah, it did take stock,
right?
Ima tell him the whole fucking
time, but the afcs week, all right.
Fucking week.
The NFC has been far superior
to the AFC for fucking years.
All right.
But the thing is you got Brady and
Bella check and a little bit of luck and
that's how we got to the fucking super
bowl last year. We still almost won.
But that doesn't change
the fact that our defense,
all right.
Oh we do good against the mediocre teams
and the so called good teams in the AFC.
But I'm telling you right now, we'll be
lucky if we get by the Broncos. Okay.
You let up fucking 40 something
points to a second year quarterback.
I can't help you.
Why is my voice cracking?
Cause they've been screaming
at the fucking TV for three
hours watching the damn
thing.
Um,
yeah.
If the 40 niners actually had a
quarterback, they would have scored like,
you know, a more experienced quarterback.
I'm not shitting on their, uh,
their guy there with the soul patch,
whatever the fuck his name is at a Boise
state who could have played baseball.
Ali. Yeah. But he had one fucking
Shiny Tatiana. I mean, fucking times.
You can tell that story.
Um,
yeah.
I mean, he missed like two guys who will
have like three steps on our safety.
I Dunno. Just fucking brutal. But
I knew it was going to happen.
I knew it was going to happen. You know
what I mean? I mean, I hate to say it,
but if you know, if the 40
niners had Aaron Rodgers, uh,
drew Brees of fucking, you
know, Eli Manning get, Oh, it's,
we can't compete with,
that kills me. Kills me.
I don't what the fuck we have to do,
but I, you know, we're all right.
We're all right in the box as they say,
but I swear to God,
our fucking pass defense stinks.
I don't,
I don't keep it just, it was, you know,
it was enjoyable watching the 40 niners
celebrating and stopping around and
doing that because
they're doing their job,
all that dumb shit that every
fucking athlete does. Now, you know,
you fucking get a layup for
two points and then you go
scare children than the front
row. Like, like he had this like,
you're actually in 300,
you know,
why don't you just fucking bend over
and blow yourself at that point.
I really enjoyed watching the 40 niners
do that and then get that deer in the
headlights look is Brady
calmly does just dismantled.
They're fucking awesome defense and tied
it up and scored like 34 points in like
a basically a quarter. I did enjoy
a 31, whatever the fuck it was.
I did enjoy that.
Watching them have to stand
down and actually having
seen that glazed over look.
Oh and now the phone rings.
Now the fucking phone rings.
Could anything else be
going on with this podcast?
Just seeing that glazed over look on
Jim Harbaugh's face w was enjoyable,
but I fucking love that
guy. And I loved the, uh,
the fake punt call and the
first quarter on your own 40.
Was that when I was awesome.
I had to respect it.
It's like this guy is
going for the juggler,
but I mean those guys honestly could've
been up like 21 nothing after like six
minutes in the game. Um, yeah.
So they had golf desert,
right.
Nice big bucket of ice water to the
face of delusional patriots fans.
That's, that's what it is. That's
where our defenses against, um,
the elite teams, you know, sucks.
I'm not happy about it and um,
okay.
Yeah, I'm not fucking happy about it.
I just wish I, we could, we could. Oh,
for fuck's sakes.
With your fucking,
you know what I hate about this fucking
stupid phone besides everything.
So you have the fucking thing on
mute. It's still makes noise. Like,
like I get important phone calls,
right. Clia. What am I the president?
Does it really need to do that? Even
when you fucking put it on silent mode,
it still vibrates. I guess I could
just shut the thing off. Right.
I never, I never even thought to do that.
That's great. I worked that out. Oh yeah.
Of course. My password doesn't
work on the fucking computer.
This is just going to
be one of these days.
You and I know he's going to be one of
these days is I took my dog out for a
walk and um,
she took a shit and I'm like,
Rappaport I went to pick the fucking
thing up right now and I had my headphones
on and as I bent over to do it,
my headphones fell down and almost
landed in the pile of dog shit.
And uh,
okay.
Rather than laughing it off like
somebody with rosy cheeks would, um,
I'm a cynical bastard,
so I took that as an omen on how
this day was going to be and uh,
it's lived up that way.
Okay.
I had a bowl of cereal this morning.
I almost fucking died.
Okay.
You know what's funny?
The lovely
Nia was literally maybe seven feet away
in the other room and never checked on
me.
Could give a shit, you know,
and you know what that is?
It's like we've been together when you've
been with somebody as long as I have,
they just,
it's not like they want you to die.
It's a combination of two things.
They, they, they just tune you out.
So I could've been in there
talking to her about how, you know,
my headphones almost fell into
the dog shit this morning.
Or I could have been almost
choking to death. Either way.
She doesn't even hear it.
And then like subconsciously it's
not that they want you to die,
but they not fatally.
But if you could die for like three hours,
you know, I, I don't think
that they would be upset.
You just Sorta,
you know,
drag you over and put you behind
the couch and just, you know,
fantasize about being single again for
like three hours and then you, you,
you know,
you wake up like in one of those,
those movies with Kiefer Sutherland
was that movie call shockers wasn't
clockers. That was likely. I don't know. I
don't know what the fuck it was. Anyways,
this is what happened and
I was eating a corn checks.
I'm a big fan of the checks family.
All right.
This isn't some sort of subtle advertising
I'm trying to put in here. Okay. This,
this, this is coming from my
heart, not my wallet. All right.
I like to check serious.
I'm not into rice checks.
Man has nothing to do with
World War II or Vietnam. Okay.
I just don't like the taste of them.
Okay.
I'm not coming at you with some red
state, Shayla. I ain't, ain't nothing.
It got fucking raw Sienna and after what
happened over there and a of the DMZ,
I'm not coming at you like that.
I just don't like the taste of that one.
I either go corn checks or I go week
checks. So here's the deal. Yeah.
You know what I noticed the other
day is this, this morning when was,
I was almost choking
to death on my cereal.
Was all cereals kind of the same color.
You know what I said?
It's all sort of fucking, just
different kind of browns and that weird.
Isn't that weird? That that
would go through my head is
I'm almost Diane choking.
That fucking bad eighties comedian
analogy went through my head that well.
It might've been my last thought.
You know?
Well like it's like a topic
you'd hear on like NPR.
All things considered today we discussed
the different shades of Brown and
breakfast cereals. I don't care if
you're eating rice checks, corn checks,
we checks rice krispies or corn flakes.
The all too familiar off color bandaid
brown. I'm an old things considered.
Um, we listen to NPR.
Neil listens to that shit.
She's such a fucking nerd and she always
has it on. And um, I and you know,
I don't know,
there's really no good radio stations
out here as far as like playing music out
here in la. I don't know why. I don't,
I dunno what goes on out here,
but evidently, uh, these,
the two bands that they play, they play in
like, it's still 19, the early nineties.
They play ice cube all the time.
Bad Ass when he come to my town, bad app,
like, like, I don't know why they play it.
Like they play it enough
like you think he did,
he died or something,
you know, and then, uh,
and then they also play the,
uh, who were those guys?
La La la La, la La. Yeah.
Oh, but that, that held at
bay obey, whatever the fuck.
They are pretty fly for a white guy.
They play them all the fucking time.
Yeah.
You know, like everybody's still
walking around in flannels going, hey,
have you heard the new
Pearl Jam man? Um, anyways,
so here's the story.
Okay.
I basically,
I go to get my fucking box of corn checks.
I pick up the box and Mila and notice
it's pretty light. You know, pour it in,
get a full bowl,
and there's like an eighth of a box left.
Now I could be a Douche and put the
box back and give Nia false hope. Oh,
I want a box. You know, I want
a bowl of cereal, you know,
and then she grabs the box and she feels
the likeness. Then that panic comes in,
you start to sweat like all, fuck,
you start pouring it out. Come on man,
keep going. And there's only an
eighth of a bowl left, you know,
the Douche puts that back in the cupboard.
The gentlemen,
the refined individual like
myself, you just say, all right,
I'm going to have a little more serial
than I usually have. So that's what I did.
All right?
And I start eating the fucking cereal
and I'm wolfing it down cause I know the
podcast is a little bit late and I'm
going to get a bunch of shit on Twitter,
right?
So I get about halfway done with my bowl.
I take the box of cereal and I pour that
last a thing. And you know the deal,
the last part of the box, that's the
most dangerous part of the box. You know,
you got half of it, half of it's Cyril
and the rest of it's all fucking powdered.
So all the power goes on my,
on the top of the cereal,
I started eating the shit and I'm doing
that, you know, eating so fast you're,
you're eating an inhaling through
your fucking pie hole. You're
doing that shit.
And I had a half a spoon of powder and
the other half was the cereal and I
inhaled the shit and I, my,
my throat just closed off.
I thought I was gonna.
I thought at the very least I was
going to pass out to the point I was,
I was debating as I'm coughing and hacking
away and Nia is completely ignoring
me.
Um,
I'm sitting this Ponant,
I'm thinking,
should I make them loud noise in the
kitchen or should I run to, you know,
five steps to the bedroom.
But then I'm thinking what that,
but like take up too much oxygen.
And um,
I basically was choking on this shift
for three straight minutes in Nia.
Didn't move a fucking muscle,
didn't move a goddamn muscle.
And when I finally,
I finally realized I was gonna live,
I was so pissed at her
that, you know, you know,
like after you get done choking like you,
your voice is like,
it's like turned down to one. So you're
trying to talk just like, you know, open,
you know, that type of shit. I
basically said sarcastically.
Thanks for helping in the,
I was just choking for three minutes
voice and all I get for neo is like, oh,
I'm sorry. Are you okay? No.
Is there any way to start the fucking day?
I don't think this was that even funny.
Was that even remotely amusing to you?
I don't know.
I almost died this morning.
I'm just how I don't care
if I'm funny or not, Cleo.
Um, all right, let's do it.
Let's do a little advertising here and
then I'm gonna talk to you about this 30
for 30. I watched called broke.
All right. Um, where are we?
Oh, we got a new, we got new advertising
this week. Everybody cascade studios,
cascade studios on Santa Monica
Boulevard out here in Los Angeles.
We got a local ad here.
Um,
this is based a rehearsal studio pull.
If you're in a band basically,
and you need a rehearsal space.
Cascade studios is the number one place
here in Los Angeles. This is where,
and when I got out and I played drums and
I tried to pull off that bottom stuff,
trying to get my foot is
fastest. His, this is where I go.
I go to cascade studio 66,
11 Santa Monica Boulevard.
If you want to go down
there with your whole band,
they got a five piece drum kit in every
room with high hats, two guitar amps,
bass amp, pa system with three mikes.
Symbol rental is only five bucks.
Um,
or if you're just a drummer like myself
and you want to go down there with your
iPod and beat the hell out of
a kit and have a great time,
he charges you 15 bucks for an
hour. I highly recommend it. Um,
I go down there all the time.
If you go down, asked for Joe,
tell him the Monday morning podcast
Ascensia and as always everybody,
it's stamps.com I'm with the holidays
all almost here you don't have time to go
to the post office is traffic.
This parking,
there's somebody in front of you is going
to have like 90 boxes that they send
it out to. All their grandkids, you
know, is they take out the change person,
they're handy, shaken, right? It's
going to be packed with everyone.
Mailing out holiday gifts is what
I'm trying to say and packages.
So what do I do?
I use stamps.com instead with stamps.com
you can void all the hassle of going to
the post office during
the busy holiday season.
Everything you would do at the post office
you could do right from your desk or
your apartment, wherever
the hell you're at. Um,
buy and print official US postage
using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or
package the instant you need it.
Then the mailman comes and picks it up.
It's so easy and convenient.
You don't have to go down to the post
office and deal with everything that I
just described. I use stamps.com to
send out all the merchant from my shows.
You should do it too. Well, I guess you
shouldn't unless you're doing a show,
but whatever.
If you've got all these Christmas gifts,
yeah,
that's the way to send it out. Stamps
dot right now get this special offer.
When you use my last name Burpee,
you rr for a no risk trial plus $110
bonus offer and includes a digital scale
and up to $55 free postage.
They given you $55 during the
holiday season. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com right now.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top
of the page and type in [inaudible],
B u r r that stamps.com
enter [inaudible] B.
U. R. R. Alrighty. Back to the
podcast. So I was watching, um,
I was watching one of those
30 for 30 [inaudible]. Um,
and they did this whole thing on, on
athletes going broke. It was really bad.
There's a ton of people who've gone broke.
Most of them didn't want to do the
documentary. Like why would you,
you know what I mean?
Hey,
you want to talk about how you completely
fucking blew it. Now I don't, I don't,
I resent the fact that the
end of your documentary,
you're going to be running a list
with my name on it. You know,
that's what they had at
the end of it. But, um,
I was watching it and
I felt bad for people,
but after a while it was just the same
fucking story over and over again.
And it's as much as I want to say that
if I was 21 years old and you gave me $1
million, that I would probably fuck
it up too. I just don't think I would.
You know,
I love these guys. You know, I got a
check for $55,000 and I saw hummer.
I had to get it talk to the guy down to
$49,000 and it's like if you just got a
check for 55 fucking grand after
paying all the people in your life,
your agent,
whoever else she got,
where else has taken a
geolocation, whoever else takes
a chunk out of that check,
whatever's left out of that,
the government's going to come in and
take a 40 40% where if you get a check for
55 grand,
I mean you already got left 20 grand and
he just went out and bought a $50,000
Hama. I Dunno. But anyways, the point
I wanted to make was at the end of it,
you have to show and all these
people going through this hell,
they have this guy that who's supposed
to be evidently some sort of a financial
advisor and in the end they were talking
about Lebron James going to eat is
going to be,
he has a potential B other
than tiger woods pre divorce,
um, a billionaire athlete.
And they get like,
how exciting is that? And they go,
what, what would your advice be to this,
to Lebron James on how to hang on to
his billion dollars? And the guy goes,
he goes, don't blow it. Keep it simple.
Count your money.
It's what he said.
It's,
it might've been the dumbest thing
I ever heard. And I immediately,
I had no sympathy for anybody
in the fucking documentary.
It's just
like, even like, why is
this guy on this document?
Who the fuck is that guy? That's the
guy who manages money that's, hey,
I got $1 billion. How do I hold
onto this? Where should I invest it?
What do I do? What advice do you
got from me? Oh, it's simple.
Don't blow it. Keep it simple.
Count your money. All right,
thanks a lot. I'll be, I'm out of here.
Fucking ridiculous.
We,
it was basically,
it was an hour and a half of listening
to morons telling you what the fuck they
bought with all their money.
And I don't know, I felt bad,
but there was another part.
It was just one guy that I
really felt bad for because
it was the hurt that he had.
You know,
like Andre rising was on the thing
and he's sitting there in his suit,
was sunglasses on, mirrored sunglasses
during the interview and just right there,
it's like, yeah, dude, you, I'd give
you another million if I had it.
If I gave it to you, you'd,
you'd, you'd fucked that up. Why?
Because you're sending here in a
shiny suit with fucking sunglasses on.
Look like Michael Jackson at the
award show. Right. So anyways,
the one guy who actually really
bothered me was, if you ever watch it,
it's 30 for 30 broke.
There's a guy who's sitting there and
he's just ever so slightly lean to one
side and the just the,
the pain
in, in his voice. He's just
just sitting there going,
ah,
I made
$75 million in that career,
add meal at Mercedes,
got a homo,
got me a boat.
It's just sitting there looking down on
his knee, like playing with his pant leg,
a jet ski and,
and you just, I had to look
away. It was fucking brutal.
But the rest of it was just a
bunch of knuckleheads. You know,
I felt bad for Bernie Kosar
to cause burning coals are,
uh, you know, I don't know.
It seemed like his dad took his money. I
don't know what the fuck it was. It was,
it was, it's, it's a really, it's a, it's
a great, all the 30 for 30 is are awesome.
This one is awesome,
but they just should have had a couple of,
they did,
you know,
something that's not true cause
they had like four or five guys.
There was only two people who
really came off like morons,
but they were just so,
they were such morons that I
felt it tainted the whole thing.
Ah, that is, might have been
the dumbest thing I ever heard.
What is your advice? Don't blow
it. Simple. Count your money.
All right. I'm sorry. Was that
even remotely fucking interesting?
I love watching those 30 for 30 is I
got to watch the Bo Jackson one. Um,
there was just something about that like,
you know, for as much as they showed
the amount of people that went broke,
there's been so many more people
in the league that didn't go broke.
So really weren't you just
showing a select group of morons,
you know,
who we're going out and buying a corvette
and stick in a fucking hot tub in the
back of it, you know, living
week to week on paychecks.
I mean, I just don't think that
most people are doing that.
I would really think that if,
if I was barely on the team,
I would be saving every dime.
I know I would.
I've done that in this business. I've
never fucking, you know, it's common.
If you're in any sort of entertainment,
you know it's coming and the day it's
coming is the day you think that you're
good and that you made it.
That's when somebody comes in with the
hood on and the sickle and they just
fucking Chop Ian half and then that's it.
And then you're that guy on TV.
Fucking lean into one. But that's
why that guy was leaning to one side.
They had a twist his torso back onto
some fake legs as he sat there going,
I got me a cabin,
bought a mountain.
You know, you think that if you had $75
million that you could never anyone,
that shit goes in and when, when, when
it goes, uh, they, there's nobody around.
Um, anyways, I gotta wash it a few
more times. I feel like this comp,
there's some sort of comedy in there. I
just don't know if I got to it today. Uh,
anyways, I've been drinking like a fucking
mad mad lately. I really have to stop.
I just keep going to these, these
frigging Christmas parties, you know,
and they got booze there.
So yeah, we, you know,
something maybe that if I got like
a zillion dollars, maybe that,
that that's what I would've would've
done would've gone out and become a
complete frigging booze bag. Now what
the fuck did I do with my notes here?
Oh, for Christ's sake, I swear to
God, this is just, it's not my day.
It's not here. It's not there. It's not
here. It's not there. What the fuck is it?
There it is. You know what?
Let's read a question here.
My brain is suffering from lack of
oxygen here. Let's just read a question.
College do wet. Hey Man, I'll
keep this question short.
I got my eye on this broad.
She heard me playing music in the dorms,
knocked on my door. I invited her in
and we talk for a bit. Jesus Christ.
Dude, I don't think you need any advice.
That sounds like you're already there.
She just heard your talent and
came knocking on your door.
What more does she have to do?
You know,
pull up her dress and backer weigh in
anyways. Oh, she said she wants
to do duets together. My fault,
I didn't realize she was also
in the business. Uh, Jesus.
Um, anyways, second time
I wasn't playing music,
but she knocked on the door and
started talking about duets again.
Not sure if she wanted
to play then or what,
but I was busy studying so I invited
her in again and we talked yet again.
Okay.
Dude,
you're only going to get so many at
bats where it's going to be weird if you
finally fucking make a move. All
right. What are you doing? I I,
this is, where did that
come from? Um, anyways,
I figure I'll invite her down.
Okay.
Uh,
I have a single dorm with her instrument.
Once the workload,
it didn't really sound good.
What I figured, I'll invite her down. I
have a single dorm with her instrument.
Once the workload,
after holidays,
debt dies down and just kiss
her and see what happens.
Oh, this is just a band geek. All
right. What are you doing? Hey,
come on over and, and
bring your, your bassoon.
And then she's going to walk
in and you just gonna kiss her.
Please tell me there's going to be some
sort of preamble of making her laugh or
something. You at least don't try
to light a candle anyways. He says,
how does that sound?
Any advice?
I've had almost no interaction with
her before or after this, by the way.
Uh, okay. He goes, love the podcast.
Keep it up. You're a great guy.
Just kidding.
Fuck you.
All right. Um, what, what, what
do you want to do with her?
You just want a banger. If you just want
a Banger, well, you have to do is just,
do you have to stop
acting like a gentleman?
Okay.
And I don't mean that in some
sort of gropey disgusting manner.
What I mean is you have to,
you have to not
just say the shit you thinking.
All right?
Just say the shit you thinking and
say what you want to do. All right.
If it's one of those, but if this
girl, but if the girl is like, uh,
I dunno, she's more walled off. I
don't know what the fucking word is.
I think that brain cell died when I
inhaled the power powder this morning. Um,
she's more walled off that.
I don't know if she's like a nerd.
I don't know what to tell you.
I never was able to interact with
female nerds beyond just talking to them
because they would just so fucking,
I don't like everything was like awkward.
So after that I was just like,
you know what?
I could literally rub one out
faster than it's going to take.
Yeah.
For me to figure out just
how to get her glasses off.
So yeah, dude, just invited down
fucker instrument, you know,
get the music out of it and just
say, hey, you want to come deal?
I'm watching a movie tonight. Just get
her over there. All right. I Dunno.
I don't know where you've gone
with the conversation so far.
If it's going to seem weird,
if all of a sudden you sit in
there and you're Hugh Hefner robe,
but that's the vibe I
would have tried to break.
If you just want to bang her thing,
that's what I would do. If you want,
if you want to date this girl,
then I take her out.
But if you just want
to bang her, you, you,
you have to start acting like a fucking,
um,
CRAs individuals sooner rather than later.
You know,
you know what's a good way to kind of
bring it into this sex thing is if you're
watching TV and just start talking
about some fucking girl on the TV,
how hot you think she is
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
Hopefully that'll spin her
around and be like, why?
What do you find attractive
in a woman? And then you just
fucking blah, blah, blah,
blah. Well, let's take a look at you.
You kind of get your fucking Teddy's
air and sitting in my phone, right?
And then you're in.
Yeah,
right. Does that work? I
owe but works for you, sir.
Does I think you are a great guy.
You're a great guy. Cause you know,
you're sitting in a dorm and
you're, you're practicing
your fucking Piccolo. Um,
all right, next one. Actually,
you know what that reminds me of
a long time ago, long time ago,
I went to this girl's dorm and
she wanted me to, and I wanted to,
and I didn't know how to
fucking bridge that gap.
And we sat on her fucking single bed
for like till my ass fell asleep and I
finally ended up just, I just finally
just said, I have to just get out of here.
I don't know how to, you
know what I mean? I don't,
I don't know how to
fucking crack the safe.
So I should have been a little more
empathetic. God, I was pathetic.
I was, I was fucking pathetic.
Not Saying I'm, I'm, I mean,
I think that's been a through line
in my life, just being pathetic.
But it's sort of morphed, you know, every
time I feel like, oh, you know, hey,
I can kinda get that settled. Then
there's a new thing, you know,
like say podcast.
I
feel like this is a pretty pathetic
attempt this week, don't you?
Well go fuck yourself. Hit
the stop button. I don't
give a shit. I really don't.
This.
One of the great things about this,
this podcasting world is you
really don't have to give a fuck.
What the fuck is the man? Great
thing. There it is. Hey everybody,
this holiday season, this holiday
season, think the man great.
What does the man great you ask?
They're made of a hundred.
There were 100% made in America.
Cast iron grilling grades that are
revolutionizing the way people grill,
um,
named one of 2012 best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine.
Now come on. Men's health
magazine. You know,
they're trying to teach guys how to be
guys a guy grilling it doesn't get any
more manlier than that.
And there was named one of
2012 best grilling accessories.
I don't know what else need to know.
May Migrate to the perfect gift this
holiday season. Click on the man,
great banner on Bill bird.com on the
podcast page for their 1999 holiday
special. This is a $20 gift
that I'm telling you. It's
going to change your life.
This is such a great gift to get your dad,
okay?
If your dad's a man and he grills,
he's not upstairs eating Bok Choy,
you know,
get dad goes out and he shoots a pheasant,
ties it to the uh, the rear view
mirror and drives home with it.
Letting the blood dripped down on
the radio. This is what you want.
You want the man, great system. Get it for
him again. It's the man that's the man.
Great Grill enhancement system or to
today at bill [inaudible] dot com.
Click on the podcast page and a and
get yourself one today for only 1999.
The holiday special. Alrighty. Okay,
there you go. The fuck was, that reminded
me of something in the middle there.
The hell was I going to
talk about? Oh, I know.
You know what?
I was going to make a,
I was going to try to make
this shepherd's pie this week.
Every once in a while I get like really
into cooking and it's usually when I
have a doubt downtime in this business
and this time of year I always take a,
I always take some time off, you know,
I don't like working over the holidays.
I did enough of those fucking awful,
uh, New Year's Eve gigs. You know,
you're in some God forsaken fucking
strip mall in the middle of nowhere.
You all by yourself. You go
on stage, you got like a 50,
50 chance that they already handed
out the fucking noise makers.
You standing up there eating your balls
and then they make you do the countdown,
stop your act. Did I talk about this
last week? I feel like I already did.
I'll fast forward to this shit.
And then you gotta somehow,
then they want you to continue
your act after the countdown.
It's still worse fucking thing ever.
And everybody's hugging and
kissing and that type of shit.
You're standing up there by yourself,
like the absolute, you know,
cliched entertainer,
you know,
sitting there crying and your
Tuxedo. So anyway, so I usually,
I take this time of year off and I, uh, I
start, I always get, I get into cooking,
Cleo, stop staring at me.
Come here, stop staring at me.
So anyways, um, I'm a big
Mario Batali Fan, right?
So I made these braised short
ribs that were the fucking shit.
I went out and got myself a Dutch oven,
you know,
which because of that joke
is really been ruined.
There's no way to fucking say Dutch oven
and cooking without somebody thinking
about somebody farting under the
blankets in Poland. It over your face.
But I made these braised short ribs
that have been the shit but niggas on a
fucking diet. So she's not eating any of
them. So I ate like half a pig myself.
And I don't think my belly is
ever been rounder or wider.
I have like one of those toddler stomachs,
you know those little beer
bellies that they have.
You know what I'm talking
about? Cleo, Cleo,
do you want to finish
the rest of this podcast?
Do you hold and get off me?
Fuck,
a dog is so God damn needy. Um, all right,
let's continue on here with
the questions for this week.
If I can find it on my computer,
of course I can't cause this is
just how my day's been working.
I should have known I, she, you know what?
I should have gone right back to bed.
The fucking,
the second
my headphones almost fallen
dog. Shit, isn't that,
isn't that like a sign that you
should end the fucking podcast?
33 minutes and this is brutal.
All right. Douche boss.
Dear Bill. First I want to say,
uh, but, but it, but it, but B,
um,
I have all the episodes of uninformed
you did with the teen idols sensation on
my phone and listen to them every day.
But on to my dilemma,
I'm 18 and work at the finish line at
the mall and my boss is a complete Dick.
Of course he is because he's managed
managing a finish line at the mall.
You're 18.
You got your whole life ahead of Ya.
He probably fucking married the
wrong person. He starting to go bald.
He's standing there wearing
that referee uniform going, hey,
we're not you about the chuck Taylors.
You know,
I told you I was talking stock them
up in the back or whatever the hell.
They say, don't you just want
to choke them with his whistle?
Did they make you aware of whistles there
or is that athlete's foot or is that
the foot locker?
Yeah,
I dunno actually,
you know something I have like the,
the worst collection of dirty white boys
sneakers you'll ever going to see in
your life. Every time I look at my
sneaker collection, I pictured, you know,
Keith Robinson or Patrice,
he was still alive.
God dammit. I'm just
trashing me. You know,
it's funny about how much I Miss Patrice
is the amount of times is when I,
I,
I miss that guy.
Okay.
How the fuck do I tell this story
without fucking out in somebody's,
somebody told, gave a fucking
speech, you know, or whatever.
Went on some rant about the
state of comedy and everybody
thought it was fucking
amazing.
It was just one of those times where I
wished Patrice was in the room when this
person was, fuck. It was probably,
you know, was, was talking about it.
That's when I missed that dude the fucking
most, I missed him. I missed him when,
um, Penn state, that
Sandusky Guy, when he did,
when he gave the fucking interview.
Okay.
You don't have that interview when he,
he,
I think he's talking to Bob Costas
and they would go and do you, uh,
do you like little boys? And he
was like, do I like little boys?
I mean,
I enjoy their company and somebody says,
do you like little boys? This one
fucking answer. No, no, I don't.
Okay. And Fuck you for asking me that.
And this guy sitting there like, you know,
like trying to work out
the math in his head.
And as I as creepy it was to
watch that when I watched it,
I was actually laughing,
thinking of Patrice watching and laughing
hysterically and how he would somehow
get 25 minutes of material.
Yeah.
Just out of that guy trying to figure
out how to answer that, that question.
And I swear to God, like, I dunno,
we got this benefit coming up for him
and as just putting the thing together,
it's just like going through
him dying all over again.
It's been fucking brutal but good in a
good positive things because everybody
bought up the tickets, but it's
just been like this fucking, ah,
the finality of it.
It's just something like on that
I even talked to all my buddies,
like we bring him up like he's still
around and we'll talk about it. I'm like,
he's still around for five minutes before
you just start looking at the ground.
It's just fucking awful. I really,
I really do not wish that, you know,
I don't know why you would, but in,
it's not been worth even stating,
but I really don't wish this
on fucking anybody cause a,
it's really just something when I'm 80
will, if I'm lucky enough, you know, the,
we had been drinking lately. Let's us
be a little more conservative. I'm 68.
It's just something that's still
just going to be, I've just,
I'm coming to an acceptance that it's
going to be as sad when I'm that age as it
is right now and up.
So I figured I talk about that to add to
the already not hilarious podcasts that
I'm doing this week. I'd add to the
losing a close friend fucking vibe.
You know,
who's getting hurt?
It really wasn't a funny fucking week out
in the world. Uh, alright. Douche boss.
Where are we here? Um, the finish
line, he is one of those guys who,
okay that his boss is a complete
tech or it and he says, uh,
he's one of those guys who got bullied
all through high school and now actually
has some control and takes it out
on me and the other employees.
How did you figure that out as that you
just like psychologically breaking the
guy down?
Do I have to tell you something?
There's nothing worse
than watching somebody uh,
abused their position of power.
Harvard, however small it is.
You don't like this guy right here has
no right getting mad at like an athlete
who goes around being a dick
because it's like, dude,
you're doing the exact same thing. You
just can't run a four 40, but your,
your head space is the exact
same place as some, you know,
Egomaniac fucking athlete. You
just, you just suck at sports.
So you sell the gear to people,
look to go play sports.
Anyways,
he says he even steels out of the register
at work and holds the special release
shoes for him and his friends.
He's 30 years old.
And tries to fuck the 16 and
17 year olds who work there.
Oh my God, this guy is a
character right out of the movies.
You know,
I worked with a guy like this.
I used to work in a restaurant
in a long time ago. Sorry,
I'm trying to get the check
cereal out of my throat. Um,
I used to work with this guy and the,
basically like four or five of
these guys bought in to a restaurant
in the one guy who is going
to be there every day,
who's always the guy who ends up stealing
the silent partners, always get fucked.
His, his, his buy in was, he had
all the equipment for the kitchen.
So he, he, he,
he had some other failed restaurant
and he got all the equipment and uh,
but anyways, this guy was a coke head.
He used to steal out of the register.
He used to fucking, uh, try to
bang the, uh, not the Maitre d,
The fucking, uh, maitre ds, whatever,
the fucking chick who sits you down the
hot one, you know, who dresses classy,
that skirt fucking going right
over a shapely ass. Yeah.
He used to try to fucking bang them all
the God damn time and when they wouldn't
give it up, they get fired and
then he'd be bringing a new one.
If that one ended up banging him, then she
stuck around. It was brutal. So anyways,
he goes,
uh,
he harasses me and others calling our
phones repeatedly telling us to come in on
our days off and leaves voicemails
saying we are ignoring him.
Jesus Christ is my fucking
day off. Anyways, he goes,
recently he got the only cool management
manager fired because he said he was
stealing. I don't really need this job,
but we'd like to keep working here,
but don't know how much
longer I can take this.
Any advice on what I should
do would be appreciated. Uh,
sorry for it being so
long. Go Fuck Yourself. Uh,
it wasn't long at all and it just
sounded long the way I read. Um,
well if you don't need the job,
then I would, I would quit.
But what I wouldn't do is I wouldn't leave
on bad terms. I Dunno. Is
it really going to matter?
It's not like when you're 30,
if you're looking for a new job,
you're going to put on your resume.
I worked at the finish line because at
that point you're going to be into a
career. I know you say, I
don't really need this job,
but would like to keep working
here, but don't know. Oh,
so you said basically you're saying you
like having walk around money. Well,
I would just get another job,
just get another job.
Start the process of getting
the fuck out of there.
Like nothing you're gonna say to that
guy is going to change that guy and all
that guy can do is kinda make your
life difficult if you're trying to get
another job.
I at this point your life,
just know that like he's at the tip of
the iceberg of the awful life that he's
going to be living.
Um,
like just what the,
the way he sat in the table.
You don't need to do anything to him
because he's going to do it to himself.
And it would really be bad if, if this
guy was just such a negative force,
you somehow got sucked into it.
I know you probably fantasize about
punching him in the face and tell him the
guy to go fuck himself.
And then the girl that you have the
crush on at the finish line walks out arm
and arm you guys and you start your own
sneaker store right across and you watch
him get fired.
I know you've probably played that
fantasy out of you had a hundred times,
but uh, I would just get another job.
It sounded like you don't mind working.
You're not afraid of working.
You like having the money,
but you just can't deal with this dose.
So this is a great life lesson.
You do not need to be surrounded by doses.
You have the power,
it's your fucking life. Just,
he's always going to be a dose,
just walk out of his life.
Just be like, yeah, you know,
I don't need to be around this guy.
You know?
And then one day when you run into
them after you get another job, hey,
how come you left it? Just be it,
you know, cause uh, I dunno dude,
you would just end,
don't curse at them or anything because
then it gives him an excuse to not see
himself and just be like,
well, I dunno man, you the,
you just kind of creep me out the way
you were always hitting on girls who were
like 16 and 17 years old.
I mean, if that's what you
want to do, I mean, you know,
that's cool. But uh, you know, I'm
just kind of not into that. So, uh,
you have yourself a nice evening
and he'd just walk away from him.
Maybe it'll work out like
that. I have no idea. But, uh,
I try and get yourself another job. All
right. They, that's my advice. All right,
here's another next one. Ah, multiple fuck
buddies gone wrong. You know what too?
Just the fact that you had
multiple fuck buddies, uh, it's,
it's still a win. You know what I mean?
It's still a way you made the playoffs.
Hey Billy boy. First Time,
long time I got there,
I'm going to go to get right into it.
All right.
Last weekend I got a text from a former
fuck buddy who found out that I had
slept with their friend before we
started hooking up. Oh, you know what?
Go Fuck Yourself. All right. You're
crushing ass all over the place.
You don't need my advice.
I probably need advice from you.
Okay.
That's all we,
that's a secret goal of,
of a certain percentage of guys is like,
what if I can fuck her and all of her
friends before they all figure it out?
You know what I mean? It's sort of
like an action movie with your Dick.
Can I stick in and all of them
before the bomb goes off and uh,
and can I get out of town like fucking
Deniro and heat before I see all of them
coming up with the,
how dare you?
Have you ever fantasized about doing that?
And you were so good.
That is mad as they were.
They all reminisced about how great you
were and then all four of them come over
and be like, ah, well fuck he. At the same
time, if you haven't had that fantasy,
God bless you because you're evidently
a way more decent human being than I am.
So anyways, with that, here we go.
Um, he goes, she sends me. Anyway, let
me, let me just refresh your memory here.
Last weekend I got a text from a former
fuck buddy who found out that I had
slept with her friend before
we started hooking up.
She sends me a pretty heated to page
texts about how much of a dog and Douche
bag I am for sleeping with their friend
then fucking her the same weekend.
Yeah, dude, dude, you're a legend. You're
a fucking legend. What is the doing?
All you can do is just stand there
with your hands at your sides.
Take the slap to the face
and just know that, yeah,
you're a hero dude.
You banged her friend and
and her in the same weekend
and you're, you're, you, you don't front
a raw, a successful band. I mean, that's,
that's, you know, my hat's off to you sir.
Hat's off to you. Anyways,
he goes now in reality,
I had slept with the friend in late May
and then starting hook hooking up with
the fuck buddy in early
September. Oh, okay. So she
tried to make it more dramatic.
That's still great,
dude.
You seamlessly made the shift
over the summer. You still a hero.
Um, anyways, he goes to go into
a little more detailed to fuck.
Buddy had gone on several
dates and fucked once three.
Oh. I had gone on several
dates with her and fucked once,
three years prior when
we were both at college,
but then shortly after she lost interest
and we remained as friends for the next
few years.
When I say friends I mean the occasional
texts and seeing each other maybe three
or four times. All right, so
what is your fucking problem?
What is the rule?
Shouldn't this,
shouldn't the second one be mad at you
cause you fucked the other one first?
I don't know. I'll never
understand. I never understand.
What can any female,
if you're still listening at this point,
if I have any female
listeners at this point,
can you explain to me
why that makes you mad?
You know because I don't know.
There was always like,
there was always that girl that like,
you know when I was growing up,
like I can't say me because
I wasn't getting anything.
I didn't get anything in high school,
big fucking goose egg. I would make my,
my pussy getting career in high school.
I was like the first year the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers came in the league and when
winless
what was the name of their Gary hough.
Was that the name of their quarterback?
I was the Gary Huff of of Pussy in, in,
in high school. Whatever the hell are you,
I can't remember the name.
His last name was huff,
was the name of their quarterback with
creamsicle fucking uniform and well had a
suit made out of that when I was
in high school. Um, I, but anyways,
there,
there were,
there were those girls that like my
drinking buddy crew like three or four of
them out of the five had all
hooked up with her and none of us.
For me, none of, nobody was mad.
Everybody high fives fun. Great. That's,
you know, we thought it was a great thing.
I don't understand why they get so mad.
You know what it is, is I, I
just think that want to, uh,
it's a big thing with them
then that has to be difficult
and you know,
and if they,
I think they just feel like if
you bang them and their friend,
they just somehow feel like
maybe it makes them feel cheaper
that there's just, you're just fucking
hidden. It's like you're a machine gun,
you just mowed them down.
I think that they really want to believe
that they're the only one in that area
code.
You know that they are like a,
that it's like gold rather
than like pine cones.
Okay.
You got to dig for it. It's a
precious metal. They don't, they,
that they don't want to feel like
they're just like litter in the gutter.
Maybe that's what I have. No, I have no
idea by I've learned something in this.
Fuck Buddy is two words. This
guy put fuck buddy together. Um,
that's how much he's into sex right now.
He's getting,
he's literally like the fuck is his gun.
The buddy part bent over and
it's all one word. They are one.
Um,
so anyways,
he said to go into a little more
detail or I already read that part.
He said it so fast forward three years
and the friend of hers, that's the future.
Fuck Buddy said that we should
hang out after the sox game.
All right, I'm getting lost in this
with all my rambling. No, what the fuck?
So you hooked up with a former
fuck buddy. And so now, okay,
so this is when, when,
when number two comes in,
before you went back to number one.
All right,
so fast forward three years later.
Yes. So she didn't give a fuck.
So who she should be mad at is the second
one. No, but it's been three years.
You know, I really don't think anybody
has the right to be mad here. All right,
whatever. She said we shouldn't hang
out after a sox game. Of course,
I see this as a green light because
whenever a girl that you really don't know
says we should hang out is code
for I'm down to fuck. Exactly.
Did you hear that?
A guy with the fucking bassoon.
You got they speak in code.
We should hang out sometime.
That that's literally, that's
what that means. If they say,
well do you have anything?
You're taking me out.
That means they want a relationship.
We should hang out sometime.
That's what that means. Okay. And I'm
not saying 100% just say it. It's,
it's looking good. You get waved
around by the third base coach.
Um,
anyways,
where the hell am oh for fuck sakes.
I apologize guys.
When a girl says eight down, fuck. So
also anyways, so we end up fucking,
and she gets on a plane the next day to
study abroad in Europe for the summer.
Exactly. She wanted some
shoving off Dick. You know,
let me get a little last piece of
America before I go over to tremendous.
Anyways, fast forward three
months later and the fuck buddy,
all one word says that I should come
over some weekend to hang out greenlight.
We Bang,
it's great.
And we continued to do it until the
end of the month when I fly back to the
place that I now live. So a few days ago
I get the heat of tech saying I'm a dog,
I'm a Douche bag. And she thought
I was a friend, et cetera.
I say that there's nothing I can
do or say to change what happened.
And the only thing that I could say is,
I'm sorry if I hurt her and then I
am an asshole by my question to you.
Uh, Mr no relationship
psychology degree comedian is,
am I a dog for what I did?
No,
you're not.
Okay.
You're not in fuck these women who call
you up. And use you like a fuck stick.
All right.
They called you up because they wanted
some Dick and you gave it to them.
All right?
You gave him what the fuck they asked
for and then she's going to turn around
and get mad at you and then you
apologize and say, yeah, I'm an asshole.
You're not an asshole.
But you know something.
I don't think you think you're an asshole
because you're out there crushing it.
You're just fucking saying what you
know this girl wants to hear because
probably six months from now she's
going to fuck you again. Right.
You're not an asshole. You didn't
hit on the other girl. She said, hey,
we should hang out sometime. Okay.
She's giving you the green light.
You know what I mean? You're a guy you
have to take that. You gotta take it.
Women don't understand that because they
can get laid every night of the fucking
week if they want to.
They don't have to have any game
did they did it for us. It's, it's,
it's work. It's a skill. Okay,
so when somebody wants,
if it's like you're in the wild,
you got a free fucking meal,
you're going to take it.
You know I learned that in Australia
when I was looking at those poisonous
snakes and they're like, why does that
thing have enough venom to kill 200 mice?
Okay.
Why does it need that much venom?
It's cause it's out there in the fucking,
the outback and out in the outback.
Food is scarce.
So if you get a shot at something,
you've got to fucking take it down
and that's what the hell you did.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm a fucking dog. You know?
It's like, you know what? Fuck you lady.
Okay,
I'm a dog then. Then you're a whore.
Fama dog. You're a fucking whore.
Did I call you up? Did I come
around sniffing up your skirt? No,
you called me because you wanted
some dick and I gave it to you.
How about a fucking thank you letter?
Yeah.
Did you really should have
come at her like that?
Okay.
You really should've. And I got to tell
you something. And some fucked up levels.
She would actually respect you
as long as you didn't call.
Don't call her a whore. All
right? But she fucks sheet.
So w what?
What is her relationship with you?
You guys barely talk and like
whenever she's in a dick dry spell,
she fucking goes over to you like
your hertz rent a car and just fuck.
Just ride your Dick.
And then you're supposed to be exclusive
and not bang her friend who's cut from
the cloth who wants to get plowed
before she goes over to Europe.
This is your fucking fault.
You're the one that should feel used.
Yeah.
You know neither one of them wants
a meaningful relationship with you.
You know what?
This is what I say.
Just don't even ride it back and
you know something. Fuck 'em again.
Just Bang them again. Do you agree? One
gives a fuck. Next time you see her,
she wants to give you a dirty look. Just
like I don't even react to it. What? What,
what a what a fucking what?
A bunch of bullshit.
And again, I can't believe that. Like
you, we don't have a relationship.
I'm just gonna keep saying the same
thing fucking over and over again.
Why don't I,
yeah.
Let me,
I'm stuttering here.
Do you know the other day I was watching
the, uh, when I was watching the Texans,
when the Patriots played the Texans
Monday night football, right. And, uh,
yeah,
some lady at the, at the, at the,
I was watching with us and she
started giving Bob Kraft Shit.
Okay.
For having like a,
a 35 year old girlfriend.
And for those you don't watch football.
Bob Kraft was married forever,
had a family and his, uh, wife
unfortunately died of cancer,
you know,
so she dies of cancer, you know, he stuck
by his side, did the whole damn thing.
And then now he's got a new girlfriend
and she's 35 and women are mad.
They're upset about, they're upset by,
and I, I don't, uh, I don't get it.
You know,
if I die of a disease,
I don't want fucking need it to be
sitting here like some spinster,
Guam, go have a good time,
I'm dead. I don't give a fuck,
you know,
let's say I'm a ghost and
I'm sitting there watching
it, then I wouldn't like it,
but I would just fly away.
Why would I sit there watching it?
No,
start haunting them every time
they were going to have sex.
I wouldn't do that to somebody. I
just don't understand why. Like, um,
it's not like you went out and got with
like a 17, 18, 19 2021 year old girl.
She's 35,
35 at 35.
If women aren't married,
they're freaking out.
Right.
Date Book.
I, I, you know what I love,
I just love that they get
mad at the guy and it's like,
what about the girl? Why is she with
them? Okay. If he's some sort of like,
you know, oh, he's just there
because he wants a hot girlfriend.
Then what about her? She's just there
for the money so then it works out,
doesn't it?
I Dunno.
They didn't want whenever
like shit like that goes on.
That really taps into the cynical
part of me, which, you know,
if you listen to this podcast,
God knows it doesn't take. But um,
yeah,
sometimes I just, I just think that it
almost taps into that fuck buddy thing.
Yeah.
They just don't want to know how
easily that they could be replaced yet.
They want you to feel
okay.
They don't give a fuck if they,
if they try and make you feel that way.
All those stupid songs, Beyonce,
that debt to the left, to the left,
you know,
that whole song is like, yeah, just take
your shit. Get the fuck out of here.
I'll have another guy in two seconds.
You're, you're that easily replaced.
You know,
and they, they love those
songs. Those songs are,
they consider them fucking empowering.
But then when they see a
successful guy with a, you know,
a nice closet full of shiny ties,
his own sports team,
when they see that he can still
fucking pull down some 35 year old ass,
they get mad.
They start judging his character
leaving me and my mom, we
had that discussion yet. Why?
I just don't think that that stage just,
and I'm sure that there was
somebody in their 50s and he could,
who the fuck wants to get with a
50 year old? Even if you're 70,
you know,
oh fuck. You know what I mean? You
know, you're starting over again.
If you got a fucking old
car and you trade it in,
you don't trade it in on a fucking
nother old car. You get a new one.
You know,
you fucking ride that thing into the
ground and then you get to know one.
I don't know.
I'm just saying I don't have a fucking
problem with what the guy's doing.
All right.
That's it. All right, everybody, if
you like, if you enjoyed this podcast,
mmm.
And you'd like to support the
podcast and in a roundabout way,
support the wounded warriors project,
go to [inaudible] dot com click on
the podcast page and click on, uh,
the Amazon link.
If you're going to buy anything on Amazon.
Not saying you have to, but if you've
got to buy something, just go and buy it.
Doesn't change the price button
because you went through my website.
They gave me a little kickback and then
I take a portion of those proceeds and I
give it to the wounded warriors project.
So everybody wins.
You're helping out the podcast and more
importantly, you helping out the troops,
then that seems I'm kind of whoring out
their plight to increase money that I'm
making. I Dunno. There's something wrong
about that whole thing. I don't know,
do doing a good thing, but that's just
the way that whole thing set up. I,
I'm almost doing like what the NFL
is doing with, with that pink shit,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Instead of telling people the foods
that they can eat to look to, to,
to knock down the potential
of getting cancer,
they just have everybody running around
their dress like a Barbie doll. I don't,
I don't get it. And I'm guessing somebody
making some money off of it. All right.
That's all I'm saying. Um,
all right. That's the podcast
for this week. Everybody.
That's the pod pea w d cast.
That's the for this week. Thank
you guys so much for listening. Um,
NHL Hockey, I have given up on you.
They'd had given up on you. I've, I've,
I've threatened that I
was going to get the, uh,
whatever the fuck the NBA packages and
they had it for free for two, three days,
which was a great idea. And I watched
it and I'm enjoying watching the Knicks,
my Celtics, and watching the
Lakers lose. And I'm just, well,
I guess I get the Lakers
game out here all the time.
Do you know Bill Russel wrote some book
basically describing how he made the
guys around him on his team better.
And I was reading this
Bill Simmons article.
It was making me sick to my
stomach because I couldn't
finish reading it because
I think Colby is reading it,
which would really be devastating because
I don't think Colby has ever progressed
beyond where Michael j,
Michael Jackson,
Michael Jordan was in about 1989
when Michael was trying to do it all
themselves.
And
there's nothing better as a Celtics fan.
Yeah.
That when Phil Jackson isn't coaching
and Colby is just trying to do it all
himself,
there's nothing fucking better because
he's going to score 30 and they're going
to lose. And, uh, that's
what I love to see.
Uh,
wouldn't that be ironic if
it took a Celtic to teach
a Laker how to fucking win?
Wouldn't that be something? All right,
that's the podcast. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.